Je ne suis pas sûr que vous me croiriez même si je
vous le disais, mais cela devrait arriver de
mauvaises personnes ou est une ville saine, les gens
vont se blesser et arrêter vous voulez
dire en toute sécurité J'ai une idée pendant que vous
mettez un câble  courir dans New York
à la fin de la deuxième saison de leur
que le travail compte un peu perdu il a
renoncé à être le super-héros Matthew
cette autre vie tu vas brûler ça ton
cœur va avec mais au fond de lui il
croit sincèrement que la ville est mieux sur
avec lui, vous avez interrompu une enquête à l'échelle de la ville
Jessica n'a jamais voulu être impliquée dans
quelqu'un qui sauve la ville elle s'en fiche
Jessica Jones qui diable êtes-vous Mon
nom est Matthew Murdock
Je veux dire faire sortir les anges de prison
et il essaie juste de comprendre
allait faire de sa vie en ce moment c'est
ce que j'aide les gens Je pense qu'il y a
quelqu'un dont tu as besoin pour répondre à tout a
besoin d'eux à New York qui
tu es
j'ai besoin de plus de vie oui tu étais maintenant
l'existence même de New York est en jeu
le fo  ur de nous faisons partie du même
endroit Midland monsieur Murdoch
vous ressemblez à un connard votre score
qui dites-vous qu'une ancienne
organisation criminelle dont le but est
le pouvoir ultime je ne peux pas faire partie de cela
si vous me demandez vous êtes déjà ceux-ci
les gens sont incroyablement dangereux, ils sont
incroyablement diaboliques, il est clair pour eux que
la seule chance qu'ils ont de sauver New
York sera s'ils travaillent
ensemble avec vous pour le diable de Hell's
Kitchen, le détective malin le
juste X Cohen et l'enfant avec un
des poissons brillants dans ces quatre
personnages ensemble sont une sauce épique pour
se réunir, ce sera passionnant pour les
fans de toutes les émissions, c'est génial, cela
dit aussi que nous tournons clairement le dos, ils
essaient juste de prendre soin de nous,
mais ce n'est pas à propos de nous qui  serait un
héros est une cabine qui court du feu
qui y donne tout le monde
est dr.  penny
tu t'habitueras à les regarder grand j'ai
peur de leurs cornes
[Musique]